[Musique]
c'est un appel téléphonique qui chaque
fois bouleversa choix qu'a lâché 10
l'appel à son père au yémen pour prendre
des nouvelles de la famille là bas la
vie ne tient qu'à un fil depuis que la
guerre s'est installée
les bombardements se succèdent et la
famine menace 12 des 28 millions
d'habitants
[Musique]
le simple fait d'avoir de l'eau courante
de l'électricité et de vivre dans la
quiétude fait jaillir chez ajoie qu'un
sentiment de culpabilité à kingston date
en jogging on lui faisait un des deux
pays et des heurts à choix qui est
stagiaire postdoctoral à miguil mais
elle est dentiste de formation pour
pouvoir pratiquer sa profession au
québec
il lui faudrait retourner aux études un
scénario qu'elle ne peut envisager
puisqu'elle paie le loyer de ses parents
et de sa fratrie au yémen
[Musique]
akram al aussi ou s'ils se fait du
mauvais sang pour ses proches
l'avis de m très effet seuls à queue de
la guerre l'ingénieur informatique de
formation est arrivé au québec il y a un
an pour le chemin oxame avec sa femme et
leurs enfants
son emploi de chauffeur hubert couvre de
justesse les frais de subsistance de sa
famille mais il se fait même un devoir
d'aider les gens démunis qu'il ne
connaît même pas tous les mois il
organise une collecte auprès de ses amis
chaque don de 10 $ permet à une famille
au yémen de recevoir du pain pour un
mois evènement athlètes mais 200 200
[Musique]
akram et à choix ne sont pas seuls a
multiplié les initiatives pour les
victimes de la guerre au yémen par un
dimanche de novembre
un groupe de gens aux origines diverses
sont réunis où seuls restaurants et des
mines et de montréal pour planifier un
repas bénéfice le 9 décembre à
l'initiative d'une militante pour les
causes humanitaires
je suis de région et palestienne alors
toutes nos régions sont tout intérêt
spécialement les iem 1 c c'est comme le
berceau de notre culture en achetant un
billet les participants recevront un
repas traditionnel
il y aura aussi de la musique et une
présentation du conflit
les profits serviront à acheter des
denrées de base dollars ça fait à
nourrir une famille pendant tout un mois
alors ddo autant de familles que
possible et dossier de commencer un
mouvement anti guerre ici parce qu'on
voit rien et il n'y a pas de
manifestation il n'y a pas vraiment de
d'expo médiatique
le propriétaire du restaurant insiste
sur l'urgence d'agir beaucoup des
familles là-bas n'est pas de nourriture
du toit de lui là bas n'est pas à
l'électricité
pas d'internet pas de médecin
cet élan de solidarité redonne espoir à
crème et un choix qu au delà du succès
de leur collecte leur plus grand souhait
demeure le retour de la paix ou du maine
[Applaudissements]